on parlera longtemps du vol cosmique de
ces deux hommes le colonel pavel balayer
à votre gauche et son second surtout le
lieutenant-colonel alexis léonov à
droite viennent de commencer pour de bon
la véritable histoire de l'astronautique
à bord de leur grosse crotte 2 qui a
décollé ce matin de baïkonour
les deux cosmonautes volts en ce moment
autour de la terre dont ils font tour en
90 minutes mais leurs exploits
prodigieux ils l'ont accompli cet après
midi au dessus du territoire société
pendant vingt minutes le
lieutenant-colonel alexis léonov a
quitté le votre hotte 2 et s'est promené
dans l'espace vous allez le voir vous
même dans quelques instants
de la même façon que l'on vu les
téléspectateurs soviétiques pour le
moment sur votre écran vous voyez le
colonel balla gaye qui pilote le vostro
ben c'est lui le seul maître à bord dans
quelques instants
alexis léonov va sortir dans l'espace
où
oui
le voici
vous voyez nettement sur sa droite le
capot du sas qui l'a ouvert pour pouvoir
sortir du vote rod derrière la terre
sur sa gauche vous allez voir un tube
qui flottent dans l'espace ce tube c'est
le cordon ombilical le lien de sécurité
qui relie les neuf provinces robe
maintenant il va sortir complètement
voici le premier reportage de la cosmo
vision
regardez bien alexis léonov va se
laisser partir dans l'espace
il va s'éloigner d'environ cinq mètres
de son vote rhodes en restant attaché à
lui bien sûr sa main droite il a une
caméra dont il va se servir
cette caméra de télévision retransmettra
les images vers le sol
vous voyez sur la gauche le tube qui le
relie au vaisseau spatial
oui
et le voilà qui s'éloigne
pendant que derrière lui la courbure de
la terre réapparaît
pendant 20 minutes ainsi de cette façon
alexis léonov va rester à l'extérieur de
votre hotte dans l'espace
la télévision moscovite après ce
remarquable document nous a ensuite
envoyé ce que vous voyez maintenant sur
votre écran c'est à dire des photos de
l'entraînement d'alexis léonov et de
pavel bella ya ici des essais sur
tremplin les marches à skis très
nombreuses pour la force physique
on leur a appris également à filmer ce
qui nous a permis de voir ses
remarquables documents et il vérifier
eux-mêmes les résultats de leurs films
l'entraînement était toujours collectif
les deux hommes se sont toujours
entraînés ensemble radio moscou assisté
énormément sur ce quoi
hall b leiv le commandant de bord à 30
ans il est marié et il a deux filles
irène âgé de 17 ans et ludmilla âgée de
10 ans alexis léonov lui et marié aussi
le voici en compagnie de sa femme
svetlana et de sa fille victoria le
violon d'ingres de leonov c'est la
peinture
et voici la joie qui régnait à moscou
cet après midi à l'annonce de l'exploit
de léo neuf ouvriers son portrait
brandie par les moscovites
pendant ce temps le speaker de la radio
moscovite indiqué qu enfin l'homme avait
fait ses premiers pas sur le chemin des
étoiles